[Musique]
en
pas de
nous
aujourd'hui nous étions bien la loire
nous achetions
joie de rentrer de pays lointains
avez-vous bien jouer n'est plus bien
chanter avec nous c'était gentil et ça
je crois qu'il était enfant ôtez petite
fille dans mes shows faut pas tomber
nous étions gens voyagent plus koldo
entre un petit nous parlons ni fille d'à
fond
je chante déjà mis le petit
roanne
tu es trop gentil
des seuils dont nous verrons oui mais à
condition que les études conduites par
faire
patron vous serez surpris moi je vous le
garantis alors nous nous allons aussi un
bon soir
on est content aujourd'hui pour bien
longtemps
[Musique]
rené ont tous les soirs
dire aux noceurs
il a
bonne nuit fais 10 avril
patron je descend vite voir mes deux
plus grands amis dealer bonjour de ma
part mais je n'y manquerai pas car ils
ont été très sages pendant notre absence
ma chère petite seule
europe pro gbagbo
formé par
[Musique]
gouffran doucement
une fleur pour pas preneur et une étoile
pour nicolas
qu'elle est guérie
c'est une fleur qui vient de très loin
des moyens nous avons pas le tour
et j'ai ramassé plein de fleurs et des
toiles art ou
gelée cueillis dans la voix la couture
qui va nous savaient faire pour toi
[Musique]
nous nous c'est vrai que sont bons
ce trois parfums qui me plaît
un
parfum de nier par ailleurs oui oui
mon dieu
alors gros gourmand accompagnent nous au
lit tu veux ça gronde martin j'en
donnerai une cuillère au marchand de
sable
on
mais tu n'as venir jouer avec nous des
magouilles c'est promis les enfants ce
que ce miel sent bon
la chute un leurre
oh non
oui
venez nous donner dit marchons ensemble
venus est bourré 20 prenait
[Musique]
et bien tu as été gâtés ne mange pas
toutes au miel en une seule fois ou
orientent un peu je vous en garde rue
leur patron bonne nuit les enfants de
boer
[Musique]
oh
vous
mon